OpenAI公司里90%的人都在用Codex，不是90%的工程师，是90%的全公司人。
对，你前两天发的那条推文，说你打算把Codex做成史上最好的桌面应用。
是的，Codex的质量标准得定得特别高，高到让人打开这个应用去做下一件事的时候，一点犹豫都没有，觉得这就是你自然而然的选择，就像大家现在习惯性打开浏览器标签页一样，对吧？
确实，我听说你们的使用量记录一直在刷新。
是吧，走着瞧呗，反正看起来挺多人喜欢这个应用的。
你觉得为什么AI和顶尖的前沿模型就是不太擅长设计呢？
我觉得设计这事儿更难评判，因为人的品味是反馈机制的一部分，这在目前的技术下还是有点难以企及。
那现在产品团队的结构，跟几年前比，是什么样的呢？
在OpenAI，每个人都非常主动，都有很棒的想法，所以每个人都在做各种东西。并不是说大家角色本质上有什么不同，或者侧重不同，而是反过来——
实现其实不再是昂贵的部分了，昂贵的，我敢说，是品味。
你觉得是不是有一种趋势要来了，每个人都是全能的，那就是未来，还是说我们还是会继续分工为主？
我有些担忧。我听说很多公司说要砍掉产品角色，让每个人都当构建者，然后结果就是——
今天我的嘉宾是Andrew Ambrosino，他是OpenAI Codex应用的产品和工程负责人。Codex正在迅速成为人们构建产品的首选应用，也用于一些非产品工作，比如整理电脑文件、起草文档、做数据分析、读邮件等等。如果你听到最后，我们有一段录制结束后的小片段，是制作人聊他怎么在剪辑工作中用Codex。今年一月以来，Codex的使用量涨了6倍。目前每周活跃用户超过500万，我猜这个数字很快就会过时。在OpenAI内部，几乎100%的员工每周都用Codex，而且不只是工程师。Andrew是从设计师转工程师，再转产品经理的，他正在打造的这个应用，全世界越来越多的人用它来构建自己的产品。开始之前，别忘了去lenny's productpass.com看看，那里有全球最热门、最精良的AI产品，给Lenny的订阅用户免费试用一年。那接下来，有请Andrew Ambrosino。
Andrew，非常感谢你来做客，欢迎来到播客。
谢谢邀请，这是难得的线下播客，我很少干这种事，咱们看看效果如何。
看看效果。大家会喜欢这种形式的。当我们准备这次对话时，我问你最想让大家从这里得到什么，你说就是AI怎么改变产品工作的形态。
你现在工作的团队可能是AI软件最前沿的团队了，所以你确实有独特的视角，能看到未来方向，别人团队在一两年后会变成什么样。那现在产品团队的结构，跟几年前比，有什么变化？
现在作为领导者构建这些产品，最难的一点就是流程的颠倒，这点我想很多人谈过，就是任何人都能构建任何东西，对吧？我现在基本相信，从零开始，你跟这些模型对话——我们的或任何人的——基本上你想要什么功能都能搭出来。这就不一定是软件里最难的部分了，但那就像——
这真的很酷。我觉得这创造了一个环境，让人们都在创造这些东西，对吧？你给人们无限的令牌。OpenAI的每个人都很有主动性，有很多好想法，所以每个人都在构建一切。而
我觉得，你看看我们长期以来运行的产品流程，它有点相反，对吧？它一直是研究构思，可能有一些原型制作，但你知道甚至
当我们过了瀑布模型之后，它仍然有点像是，实现是昂贵的，所以你要做的是通过文档、研究、原型来预先降低所有实现风险，因为原型
和设计更便宜，这是当时的假设，而这种情况已经改变了，完全改变了。现在，我敢肯定有90个不同的探索，针对这个我们迫切需要做的功能，
我敢肯定有90个不同的小组在并行实现和尝试，对吧？
嗯，
所以我想简短的回答是，这反过来了，不是人们在扮演根本不同的角色，或者专注于不同的事情，甚至技能消失了，或者职位消失了。而是
反过来了，对吧？实现实际上不再是昂贵的部分了。我敢说是品味。嗯，但这是策划过程。就像那90次尝试中，这些有什么好的？我们应该把这些融入其他方面吗？对吧？
我们应该怎么框架化？它应该是另一个功能的一部分吗？对吧？开关里应该有多少段？嗯，你知道所有这些事情。本期节目由我们季度的呈现赞助商WorkOS带来。OpenAI、Anthropic、Cursor、
Vercel、Replit、Sierra、Clay和数百家其他获胜公司有什么共同点？它们都由WorkOS驱动。如果你正在为企业构建产品，你已经感受到了集成单点登录、
SCIM、审计日志和其他大公司所需功能的痛苦。WorkOS把这些交易障碍变成了即插即用的API，并提供了专为B2B SaaS构建的现代开发者平台。实际上，每个我投资的初创公司，
当它们开始向上市场扩张时，最终都会与WorkOS合作。那是因为他们是最好的。无论你是试图获得第一个企业客户的种子期初创公司，还是全球扩张的独角兽，WorkOS都是
最快成为企业就绪并解锁增长的道路。它本质上是企业功能的Stripe。访问works.com开始，或者直接联系他们的Slack，那里有真正的工程师等待回答你的问题。WorkOS允许你
使用令人愉悦的API、全面的文档和流畅的开发者体验更快地构建。今天就去works.com让你的应用企业就绪。品味真是个流行词。我想回到那个话题。关于90个
原型的想法。太有趣了。所以让我确认一下我的理解。在OpenAI有一个想法在流传。人们过去写文档。是的。这是我们要构建的。这是功能。这是
策略。现在你描述的完全合理，人们只是创建一个原型，你是说公司里的人们有类似的想法，现在他们不是写文档，而是创建他们的
小原型，这导致了90种不同的东西，人们可以看看，也许选择一个我们想要走的方向。是这个想法吗？
有很多这样的情况，你知道这不仅仅发生在这里。你看到很多产品负责人说PRD已死，原型当道。我实际上完全不相信这个。我认为现在发生的一件有趣的事情是，
因为实现变得非常便宜，跨越所有媒介。非常诱人直接跳到原型，特别是如果你不是工程师，对吧？特别是如果你从未写过代码，或者从未
感兴趣，或者从未有时间。真的很诱人说PRD已死。让我直接展示我的意思。对吧？但我也注意到，对于工程师来说，写很多文档真的很诱人，
很多不值得读的文档。这不是对写文档的人的不敬。而是如果实现是丰富的，那么选择正确的格式来表达你的观点非常重要。如果那个观点是关于一个模糊领域的产品
澄清，那么可能确实是一份文档。如果你想做的只是把东西放到人们手中尝试，并对交互模式进行压力测试，那就是原型。但我认为现在有趣的是，
选择媒介真的很重要。
有一个术语，一个播客嘉宾分享过，当你提到这个时我会想到，叫做“原始标记”。当设计师、画家或艺术家在画布或艺术品上画出第一个标记时，
那个标记是你开始回应的东西。所以一切都从你做出的第一个标记开始涓涓细流。而我听到你所说的是，有时原型是错误的第一步，因为那样你只是在
回应这个原型，对比另一个想法或更大胆的想法。我喜欢听到这个。所以大家都觉得，‘好吧，算了，不用再写文档、写说明、写审阅了。’但你说这些其实对特定场景还是很有用的。
确实。
对。我觉得在以前的世界里，媒介本身就蕴含了很多关于流程阶段的信息。比如，如果你看到某个东西已经像是上线版本了，那意味着它已经处于后期阶段，假设已经被验证，设计也经过审查，商业目标也不错。但现在这些都被剥离开了。
因为过去在项目没有充分验证之前，很难拿到资源去构建，而现在已经不是这样了。所以我觉得很重要的一点是，我们要明确：我们可以有原型，有文档，但我们清楚这到底在做什么吗？
因为正如你所说，你不想过分依赖一个原本只是探索性的东西，但它看起来已经像生产就绪了，比如视觉上已经可以上线，但本质上它并不代表研究的正确方向，也不是用户真正想要的，或者对业务不是最有利的。
对。我们不要过分强调“品味”这个词，但这是又一次，品味决定了做什么、如何呈现信息、如何达成目标、用什么媒介，这些都成了最重要的事情。就是这样，这在各个领域都是如此。
你说的“好品味”具体指什么？是你说要决定投资哪个项目吗？还是当你有一个东西后，判断这是否是正确的、该发布的？
对。当你想到什么是好品味、好判断，具体是什么？因为人们听到这个词，就会想‘哦，我有好品味，我知道。’实际上它是什么样的？
嗯，这有点好笑。我上网太多，我记得有一条推文，好像是昨天Linear的产品负责人发的，我可能记错了，不好意思。他提到人们过于强调品味中的美学部分，并举了Paul Graham的例子，说他显然有很好的品味，但穿着工装短裤，对吧？所以我们得把品味这个词的含义稍微拆解一下。
嗯，这里有很多细微差别。我觉得你提到的这些都包括。有美学部分，但也有系统思维的部分，比如这如何融入整个系统？还有我们往哪里去，这属于什么主题？如何呈现？很多都涉及更广泛的背景。显然，品味中也有一些具体的点，比如这个交互动效是否符合它要传达的语义？比如，它对于要表达的内容来说过于轻快了，这非常重要，我可能过于关注这方面了。
但也还有，如果我们可以构建任何东西，我们应该做成什么样？目标是什么？我们如何达成？我觉得这才是真正的品味问题。
当我听到这些时，我总是想知道，随着AI越来越强，能做更多工作，人脑在哪些方面依然有价值？感觉品味就是其中之一。我还想到，AI在真正的设计上仍然很糟糕，AI的输出并不理想。
是的。
很少有那种‘就它了，他们做对了’的情况。总感觉‘这是云设计，这是Codex的设计’。为什么你认为AI和顶级前沿模型现在还不擅长设计？
你觉得它们会达到那个水平吗？我们会达到一个‘天哪，我们搞定了’的地步吗？
是的。我倾向于认为有一些实际原因导致设计滞后，也有一些更难解决的问题。我不是做研究的，但我这么说可能会被骂。我觉得设计比软件更难打分，因为要创建一个训练模型识别好设计和坏设计的循环，比检查代码能否编译、是否按预期运行要更繁琐和费力得多，因为品味中的人的因素是反馈机制的一部分。
我还认为，实验室历来投资于让模型擅长那些能加速AI研究的事情。在编码模型的早期阶段，很明显，模型能写出正确代码会加速研究，但设计就很难这样说。不是说擅长设计就不能、不应该或不会加速，但肯定不如代码那么直接。
其实关键不在于它是否直接在那个飞轮里，对吧？这些是实际的原因，而且你知道，这些会随着模型在设计方面变得很强而消失。还有一些更模糊的事情。
那些会非常棘手。我有一小串这样的问题。一个是，什么算好设计有文化因素，你还记得去年吧，每个新网站都只是复制Linear的网站，对吧？Linear的网站设计很棒，品味很好。如果一个模型能做到那样，我会说，哇，这是巨大的飞跃，对吧？但如果一个模型每次都输出Linear的网站，那就不是挑战了，对吧？设计中有一定的新颖性比软件工程更重要。软件工程几乎希望过度依赖已知模式，对吧？而设计则不然，这里有随机性和新颖性的元素，对吧？
而且，你知道，对我来说，我花了很多时间写代码，或者监管早期Codex应用上的代码，即使模型在设计上变得很好，软件设计和所写代码之间存在一个抽象层，这个抽象层是两者之间的相互作用。比如，这个角落里的东西应该与代码库中下面的这个东西共享x、y和z，对吧？这比说模型需要成为更好的设计师要复杂一些，尤其是你知道，这不是视觉上的，那虽然是视觉设计，但要深刻得多。
这是关于抽象的，比如，如果明天我们公司进行品牌重塑，浅层的版本是我们必须一个接一个地更新263个组件。深层的版本是这两个看起来不同的东西之间的语义，它们都在列表中，都有这种风格，向用户传达这种交互模式。我认为这个抽象层对于当前技术来说仍然有点难以实现，对吧？所以我觉得，在这个过程中，你知道，我们从11月开始使用Codex应用，当时我们不是全职使用，现在我们用它做所有事情，这是一段旅程。但现在我们在使用它时实际上做的事情已经不同了。所以，问题是什么？
我知道，这是个很棒的答案。说到设计和创意，Codex应用刚出来的时候，是那么新的事物，以前没人见过。它不是终端，也不是IDE，而是这种能编程的聊天工具，你还能看到代码。
是的。
你说得对，感觉AI很难提出一个全新的编程范式。而这正是人类大脑现在仍有价值的地方，几乎是创造力和提出新事物的能力，而不是重复已有的模式。
是的，我完全同意。让我们为人类大脑鼓掌。
目前是这样。在我们准备这次对话时，你说你在听Jenny的那期节目，她是Clock Code和Co-work的设计负责人，她有一个论点，设计过程已经死了，没有时间做设计了，事情发展太快了。
就是现在直接构建，设计随着事情发展来引导。你暗示你对设计过程有不同的看法。
我们可能有很多共识，Jenny和我。我不喜欢设计流程本身，我同意她的看法，它确实已经死了。而且说实话，在AI出现之前，我就不喜欢这个流程。
你能简单描述一下这个流程吗，让大家知道设计是怎么回事。几年前我创办一家初创公司时，我们会进行设计招聘，然后有一篇讽刺文章出来，关于所谓的“案例研究工厂”，那大概是Midjourney时代的东西，对吧？它说设计师被灌输这个流程，把它看得高于一切，甚至高于所有结果，对吗？如果某样东西经历了这个流程，就有两件事是真的：第一，它会是好的，流程会保证质量和影响力；第二，如果某样东西好，是因为它经历了那个流程，即使你不喜欢它，也没人用它。流程就像用户研究，发散和收敛，是正确的框架。它总是有点学术，但我认为这真的在暴露一些东西。
它不足的地方，尤其是在实施速度上。而且这个流程的假设前提是实施成本很高，你只能负担得起建一次。
所以你需要在进行实施之前，彻底地探索问题空间和解决方案空间。然后我们看到，像Figma和Origami这类工具，你其实可以
通过更早地把交互式原型引入流程，来加速一些洞察。你可以模拟生产环境，结果就出现了那种高管们说：‘我们能不能就做个原型，然后让它’
‘直接能用？’但这是真的，对吧？这真的成了设计流程的一部分。我们把原型制作引入了设计流程。现在的问题是，你可以
把所有的实施也拉进来。但我觉得很多假设又不匹配了，你看到那个完全打磨好的原型，看起来已经准备好发布了，公司里够多的人看到它，然后说：‘我们能现在就发布吗？’但实际上
我们还在早期设计阶段，但没人会这么说，对吧？这就是我们现在的状态，就像是一堆人一起
探索，90个人会有这个想法，看起来会很漂亮，但实际上这是设计流程，对吧？把设计流程和媒介、媒体绑在一起，这才是可怕的部分。
设计师现在有更多工具来做这个流程。你可以把东西放进当前产品里，然后做A/B测试，或者就把它当作原型。现在很多公司都有那种‘婴儿版’产品，比如‘婴儿Cursor’。你在推特上见过，我们有‘婴儿Codex’，对吧？
一个大幅简化的代码库，模拟了生产应用的所有交互，因此可以更快地‘vibe coding’。
因为你可以说，如果侧边栏这样工作会怎样？如果疼痛点在这里，加个群聊会怎样？如果XYZ会怎样？这是一个巨大的工具，是设计流程的一部分。所以要说
设计流程已死，我觉得既对也不对。如果你还绑定在那些工具上，比如规格、日常细节，那它确实死了，你不会有好日子过。但如果你完全抛弃流程，或者抛弃流程的框架，比如‘我们在这个阶段了’这种意识，
那依然比以往任何时候都重要。这很有趣，因为你有各种职能的背景。如果人们看你的LinkedIn，会觉得你是工程师、设计师、产品经理、创始人。现在你负责桌面应用，我觉得设计不在你的管辖范围内，对吗？是不是有一个
独立的设计团队，还是他们归你管？
>> 看情况，每周都不一样？
>> 好的，不错。
>> 我们合作非常紧密。我们相信大家坐在一起，融入彼此，我没有...
>> 他们每周轮换。Codex的设计流程是怎样的？
>> 关于角色崩溃，存在性角色崩溃，已经写了很多。没有角色了。我们没看到这种情况。我们在Codex组织里确实看到了比公司其他部门更多的角色崩溃，
比经济中的其他部分更多。我认为部分原因是这是一个面向工程师的技术产品，所以我们的设计师说工程师的语言，我们的产品经理说技术语言并写代码。Alexander有计算机科学硕士学位，
我没有计算机科学硕士学位。所以我们看到了很多角色崩溃，我认为，描述这些团队如何协作的方式之一是，
角色之间的重叠比过去多得多。每个人的定义不再是设计在哪里停止、工程在哪里开始的边界，而是他们工作内容的平均值，对吧？所以
如果你把设计团队某个人做的所有事情平均一下，会有很多写代码的事情，也有很多产品工作，但平均来看，他们的点在这里，对吧？如果你
画成图表，这也说明了流程。尤其是因为整个Codex应用都是通过‘dogfooding循环’来塑造的。我们所有人都有一种愿望，就是
尽可能在应用里做更多事情，即使它不是最佳工具，这样它才能成为最佳工具。所以很多设计工作，我们都是通过使用应用来做的，然后说：‘这有什么问题？’这是我们做的一整套事情，就是
我们往往不去改进流程，以便把产品做得更好，这确实是个让人很不舒服的处境，但你知道，每周都在变。我非常喜欢这一点，比如，你是什么？
你的角色取决于你把时间花在什么事情上。如果你的工作大多是产品经理的活儿，那好，你现在就是个产品经理。
对。
如果是工程，那你现在就是个工程师。
我感觉OpenAI是不是第一个把员工称为技术人员的公司？
不，我觉得这可能始于施乐。我实习的第一家公司叫Up There，也是这么做的。
这早就有了，但现在更普遍了。你知道，这在以研究为导向的公司里算是一种传统。
对吧？好的，明白了。所以它源于研究，但我感觉这似乎预示着未来的一种方向。就是我们把所有人都叫技术人员，你的职能不固定。你
不是非得划入产品经理、技术或设计的某个类别。你觉得长期来看我们都会这样吗？你觉得职能还会继续存在吗？比如仍然有产品经理的技能、工程师的技能和设计的技能。
对。
然后人们会说我是设计师，或者你认为会像人们说的“建造者”那样，有这种崩溃发生，每个人什么都是，那就是未来，还是你觉得我们还会继续
主要分工？有些事我挺担心的。我觉得有些公司喜欢走极端，喜欢赶潮流，听风就是雨。我觉得，消除角色概念的部分危险在于，它会危险地消除“专业领域有可知最佳实践”的想法，对吧？我听说很多公司说，我们要取消
产品角色了，我觉得这是个馊主意。然后每个人都会变成“建造者”。结果就是，整个产品学科积累起来的那些真正的实践、真正的经验、真正的流程，全都抛弃了，因为人们觉得“哦，我写了点代码，对吧？”那可不是好事。我欢迎那种“这不是你的领域”的界限消失，但这里有个平衡，
就是不是每个人都能做所有事，无论是广度还是深度，对吧？这就是为什么管理者不会消失。
不是每个人都能做所有事，而且每个学科都有它的技能成分。我觉得很多工程师有种毛病，就是认为工程是技能，写代码就行，其他角色就是凭感觉。
但事实并非如此，对吧？你可以用Excel，但你没法在财务团队工作，对吧？就是那种感觉。
对。我觉得还有一点就是，你想不想做这个工作？我是否想……
我觉得现在更多是，换角色更容易了。学习最佳实践更容易了。你不会把自己的有效性绑定在是否会用某个具体工具上，对吧？更像你能不能
进入那种心态，学会哪些有效哪些无效，然后专注于此，对吧？我曾经长期觉得自己不该当软件工程师，因为我不关心汇编语言或者背TypeScript语法。你知道，一直有些这种守门员式的部分，比如“擅长这个角色就是擅长这个工具”。
我觉得那种东西开始消解了。我只是觉得人们会把这事儿夸大。
你那个Codex团队是什么样的？有多少工程师、设计师、产品经理？团队现在的构成是怎样的？
每次有人问我Codex团队有多少人，你还记得我的回答吗？对，我说大概在10到几千人之间。这是个玩笑式的回答，但也很真实，因为确实……
这可以看作是大家在这里所有努力的集大成。
无论是模型研究、如何让模型擅长编码和浏览器使用，还是模型个性，以及前端产品工作，
所有这些都汇成了这个产品。同时，我们并不会每天从成千上万的人那里接受随意的PR。所以我们有一个双位数的工程师团队，
设计团队大约一半规模。还有一些产品人员，不过产品职责更多是自我防御性的，我认为在Codex或桌面端的所有人中，有一个共同点就是主动性和品味。
很多前创始人，或者在大公司里做创始人型工作的人，很多在OpenAI有极强品味的人。我们让团队变得非常大，所以我们没有那么多管理层。
没有管理层，但团队相当大，主要是个人贡献者，我觉得这挺好。
你用了“区域防守”这个词来形容产品工作，我觉得挺有意思的，这也映射到设计上的转变。你就像是去管理和协调，能多谈谈区域防守对产品人员来说是什么样的吗？
是的，我和亚历山大就这个比喻聊过很多次。如果两个产品人员合作太紧密，往往不是好兆头。作为产品人员，你有点像要做一种受力导向的活动，看看哪里有缺口，尤其是在这个新世界里，策展、引导和校准很重要，有大量的混乱发生，
人们到处抛想法，整个自上而下的多年规划行不通了。所以现在我们需要的品味制造者，从产品概念到产品成型，一路引导。这意味着基本上你需要覆盖整个公司。
所以你们分散开，说：“好吧，谁最擅长什么？我们之间留出一些空间，这样我们就能全面覆盖。”然后你填补空白，你会说：“听着，我们要招有产品思维的工程师，我们不希望一堆人写着代码，然后需要整个团队来审核产品一致性。”
我们希望每个人都有这些技能，但我想人们深入专攻的东西得变。
这绝对是我和你这样的朋友多次聊到的一个主题。现在最有价值的人，一个能把想法从概念做到成品，并且有品味知道这很棒，就是这种高能动性、高品味的人，就像你描述的那样。
这是不是就是你们招聘时考虑的，谁能在这个新世界里表现出色？
对，我觉得这是核心。这也说明了我如何看待个人贡献者和管理层，不是说管理层会消失，也不是说每个人都是个人贡献者，而是现在每个人都既是个人贡献者又是管理者。
如果你是个体贡献者，你不是一个字符一个字符地敲代码，你是在管理某种东西，你在管理代理，管理工作流程，这些工作汇聚起来完成某个目标。如果你是团队管理者，你也是在干同样的事，只是粒度不同。
我通常看重对专业的精通，但更重要的是品味，能在无限内容中分辨出什么是信号，什么是噪音，因为你会拥有无限的token，而我们不能只做垃圾。
你提到规划，在变化这么快的情况下，路线图规划变得很难。
是的，我猜尤其是在我们的世界里。
唔
人们总是对我很恼火。是的。
>> 因为事情在不断更新，一切都在变化，对吧？你们团队是怎么规划的？你们会提前想多远？计划是什么样的？是电子表格还是
Markdown文件？计划最终呈现为什么形式？是的，我觉得我们在规划上并没有做什么革命性的事情。我们在规划上并不聪明。我认为基本要点是，时间越近的计划，需要越详细。
并不是说我们不计划九个月后的事情，而是那些计划只能保持非常模糊，因为现在你对九个月后的计划添加的任何精确度都是虚假的精确度。而且你只是在浪费时间。比如
你可以说些东西，对吧？但并不是我们计划过的所有东西。我觉得研究领域是不同的。所以我不是在说研究，但在应用方面，当我们做产品时，任何你在十一月计划的东西在十二月可能还是正确的，但不是实际发生的，所以很难，真的很难做规划。我们通常需要知道，模型在什么时间线上能做什么。在我上一家公司，我
看到了这种转变，我们开始用模型来驱动功能，产品流程就崩溃了。基本上，我们不得不这样：列出未来一两年内我们感兴趣的所有事情，
全部做出原型，决定哪些现在就可以做，其他的就先放着发酵，然后每次模型有新的飞跃时，用新模型再试一次。因为
功能好不好，完全取决于它们是否足够聪明，而不是它们的形式。
>> 所以这真是关于Codex应用的一个很棒的故事。我非常确信，我们二月份发布的Codex应用，如果在十一月就准备好，绝对会在市场上失败，唯一的区别就是
十一月到二月之间的模型，对吧？我觉得这里面有很多内容，这个产品虽然一模一样，但仅仅因为几个月的时机，结果就完全不同。本期节目由Mercury赞助播出。这是一家非常不同的银行，受到超过30万企业家的喜爱，现在还有Command功能。我使用Mercury已经超过6年了，我从未想过要离开。
Mercury基本上就是由产品人员而不是银行家建立的银行。[音乐]他们让发送发票、转账、为团队成员设置虚拟卡变得非常容易，我甚至可以说很有趣。你的银行有API、原生终端CLI或AI就绪的MCP服务器吗？我[音乐]觉得没有。而且就在最近，他们推出了Command，这是一个直接内置在[音乐]Mercury中的对话界面，充当你的财务
操作员。我一直在用Command转账、查看哪些类别[音乐]花费最多、分析我的现金流，就在今天我用它查了我从[音乐]某个特定赞助商那里在过去一年赚了多少钱。我就问：“过去一年我从X赚了多少钱？”10秒后，我就得到了答案。真是太酷了。访问mercury.com了解更多并在几分钟内在线申请。
Mercury是一家金融科技公司，不是FDIC承保的银行。银行服务通过Choice Financial Group和Column NA（FDIC成员）提供。这绝对是本播客的一条主线：构建那些目前还不工作，但模型改进后就会工作的东西。还有另一条关于雄心的主线。对你承担的事情要更有野心。所以这只是你处理事情的方式，就是构建一堆可能还不工作的东西，
然后放着等模型跟上？这就是你的方法吗？
>> 是的，我觉得我们有很多这样的做法。有时候挑战在于你必须非常清楚它处于设计过程的哪个阶段。人们仍然有这种肌肉记忆，比如，“哦，我写了这段代码，所以我们应该发布它。”但应该像，“不不不，这意味着你现在有了一个产物，我们可以用它来测试未来的模型，对吧？”嗯，这在我们应用中的应用内浏览器上就发生过，对吧？
我们有一个可用的版本。我记得回到Atlas，我们在Atlas里有代理，那很酷。在那之前我们在ChatGPT里也有Operator，但没有成功。那个想法很酷，你看Operator、Atlas、Codex、ChatGPT之间有一条线索，基本上是同一个功能，但用不同智能水平重新发布，结果完全不同。所以我推动
人们不要固执地认为“这不工作，所以是个坏功能”。不，可能只是还没准备好。还有一方面，尤其是在研究中，总是渴望成为最雄心勃勃的，说“好吧，但极限情况下模型可以做到这个”，但产品端就是不行。如果你回到最初的Codex发布，基本上就是Codex网页版，而且交互体验不好，你给模型一个任务，它就会去执行，然后回来给你完成的结果，听起来没那么激进。问题是它执行得不是很好。比如它写
代码呢，确实不错，但那个形态太早了。后来云端代码出来了，完全是本地的，不连云端，也不装成很厉害的样子，也不像现在这么“AI味”十足。它会问你问题，它就在那儿待着，你不能把整个生活都交给它。那个反而效果好多了，对吧？因为那才是当时模型的水平嘛。所以我们那时候是太“AI上头”了。
我觉得这个教训我一直在想。以前啊，贝利和市场会告诉你产品长什么样、怎么沟通，现在不一样了，你可能需要发布六次这个东西才能让它起作用，而且外形可能根本不变。
听你讲做产品要考虑这么多变量，真有意思。现在有模型和研究的时间线，还有它多聪明；还要看人们能不能理解这是你在云端构建软件的方式，这是未来，得让大家为这个新未来做好准备；然后就是团队能做什么。
我喜欢那个Codex的例子，因为它又回到了“雄心”这个话题。我想问问你，有没有什么东西让你觉得“就是要更大胆”，因为模型能做的比你想象的还要多，而且有时候对市场来说太激进了，他们还没准备好。你会考虑这个吗？就是推动团队更有雄心，因为做那些可能对过去来说难得疯狂的事情现在容易多了。
确实，这是核心挑战。一旦有产品或功能存在，人们很容易发现一些小毛病，然后去优化——他们应该这么做，推特上的人也常常提醒我们，我感谢他们。人们应该关注现有功能，让它们更可靠、更好。但这也是为什么我们有自下而上的探索文化，因为有时候就像Codex应用一样，会以某种方式颠覆ChatGPT，对吧？这个会被未来的努力颠覆，这是设计的一部分。你不可能一个团队既擅长颠覆，又擅长维护产品和质量。总得设计一个流程来兼顾两者。
把事情拉远一点看。想想我们走过的路，AI如何影响我们构建产品的方式，真是不可思议。从过去我们手工写代码，就像手工艺人一样，到AI写我们100%的代码，再到你刚才说的，编码现在其实是在“驾驭”AI。你问“我的代码有多大比例是AI写的”，其实相当于“我多少次把它引导到正确的方向”，这就是AI版本的编码。现在有智能体、循环这些东西，从你看到的，人们现在构建产品的最新前沿是什么？是循环吗？还是有别的？那些最AI前沿的团队，他们现在是怎么运作的，可能大家还不知道？
对啊，循环什么的都是上个星期的事了。我们聊过这个。有个大问题一直是“产品有多少是AI写的？”这很难回答，因为如果你用去年的标准，我们现在的产品百分之百是AI写的代码。所以问题更像是，代码是有人监督写的还是没监督写的？这完全是两码事。我很欢迎这种标准的变化，因为这意味着我们在进步。我们做了很多探索，比如自主开发的软件，还有一堆“工程管理”之类的，很多不同的尝试。就像，如果晚上让AI自动清理代码库怎么办？我觉得现在所有模型都有一个毛病，就是它们往往会增加复杂性。如果研究部门有人听到，请让模型更擅长删代码。但这个问题在你想完全自动驾驶开发的时候会变成大问题，既在人类方面也在代码库方面。比如功能请求，怎么教模型哪些功能要建、哪些忽略、哪些合并重命名？怎么教模型建立正确的抽象？这些东西都在进步。我还没觉得现在就能设个循环说“改进应用”，然后它去听推特、看Slack、看邮件……我们还没到那一步，但我们在努力实现它。
你觉得我们能实现吗？你觉得会不会有一天，就像“增长”、“胜利”一样？
“斜杠目标赚钱”，比如“给我赚十亿美元”？
赢，赢下市场。
我不知道，兄弟。就像我……
我不喜欢把话说死，
说“永远不会”或者“总是”什么的。
作为产品负责人和引擎负责人，你在工作中是怎么用AI的？
有哪些用法是别人可能不知道的？
我觉得我现在拥有世界上最好的工作。不过，其中很有趣的一点是，当我们开发最初的Codex应用时，我个人的目标就是让它成为我写代码的工具。
我说，我需要把它做得足够好，以至于我能用它来构建这个Codex应用。而当时的Codex应用就是一个开发工具。我们很快就进入了“吃自己狗粮”的循环，因为你有个人使用的场景。
你会有个人的“吃自己狗粮”循环，你会说“哦，这个我做不了，我得修一下，这样我才能做那个”。然后我就能做更多事了。我们发布之后，下一个挑战就是，人们开始用这个东西做不同的事情。
然后我需要发展它，所以我得招一些人帮忙。所以我的角色同时也改变了，因为应用的角色也需要改变。于是我开始……
好吧，我需要做更多的产品探索，我需要找到正确的循环来查看每个人在做什么，并纠正那些偏离轨道的事情。所以突然之间，我就开始用Codex应用来做这些。
我仍然会写代码。我尝试让我的使用方式与我们试图解决的问题保持一致。而现在，我需要做一个电子表格来模拟这个情况。我需要做内部深度研究，了解所有在这个研究领域投入的努力，为下一版本做准备。
大概在五月，我们发布了一个或一系列版本，引入了应用内浏览器、电脑使用和工件创建功能到Codex应用中。那我想是我们“Codex for almost everyone”的发布，大家都熟悉“vibe coding”这个词。
我觉得那是我们第一次五方协调发布，我当时有一个Notion文档，记录了所有需要完成的事情。我在自动化一些流程，比如获取Pull Request的更新、从Slack频道收集信息，并更新状态跟踪器。现在这已经很常见了。
但当时我觉得自己处于管理产品发布的最前沿。简而言之，我使用Codex应用的方式基本上就是我的工作变成了什么样，以及如何让这个工具做我需要做的一切。
我早上起来，会看到每天的简报，来自我所在的3000个Slack频道，哪些事情需要我关注。我可以回复一句：
“好的，给我提五个问题，我来回答。”然后我就能做到。
你怎么设置的呢？对别人来说，要设置这样的工作流，步骤是什么？听起来很棒。
再次说，我觉得我们还在发现阶段。现在，我创建了一个自动化或定时任务，说“我会浏览我的Slack频道”。
这些是我关心的、认为最重要的事情。所以我还在定义哪些类别需要留意，并给出一些上下文。然后它就会设置成自动化任务。
刚开始运行几次可能需要一些引导。幸运的是，有了这个应用，我不需要去搞清楚怎么编辑指令，只需说“嘿，下次运行的时候，可不可以关注这个”或者“能不能降低这个工作流的优先级”，或者“嘿，发生了这个事，但简报里没提到，你能确保它包含在内吗？”所以我可以沿途指导它，它会更新自己的方式。
会通知我之类的。太棒了。不过我觉得将来，聊天机器人的形态一直有个核心问题，对吧？就是我懂怎么设置，我有时间去设置，因为对我来说这是产品探索。
但如果你不在OpenAI工作，不搞这个开发，你肯定不想自己琢磨这些乱七八糟的。我们得搞清楚这个形态该是什么样。
对，我听到的是，我觉得大家可能没意识到，你的应用其实可以很像OpenClaw那样。
对。
大家特别兴奋的是，你只要跟它说，设置这个，每天帮我看看那个，然后告诉我情况，它就像成了所有产品的一部分。
这太棒了。那别人怎么设置呢？他们就在应用里说，我想设个自动化做这个，看看我的Slack，这些是我要做的。
对，好。
对，然后应用就会说，你知道的。
对，它会帮你搞定。如果它没有Slack的集成，它会问：“我能加个Slack集成吗？”是或否？你可以点是。至少我们能做的，就是如果你不知道怎么在应用里操作，可以直接问它，对吧？嗯。
对。
我觉得这还不够，但至少是最基本的。
对，有个好例子。我建了个小应用来过滤垃圾邮件。每封进来的邮件，我在Codex里建的这个，它会判断这是不是那种我不想看的垃圾冷邮件，然后打标签放到别处。设置的时候，有一步你得去Google Cloud控制台，设置一堆Pub/Sub API和触发器。
对，那界面特别烦，还慢，对吧？然后我就想，等等，如果我让你来做呢？我说，行，帮我搞定。然后它就描述用计算机操作。
我以前真没见过它在我电脑上这样。它就直接接管我电脑开始操作了。
就像说，兄弟，我不在乎你有没有集成，我直接开始点。
对，它自己就搞定了。看着它操作真心疯狂。
对，看着它干自己的事，太神奇了。
设计连接器之间的决策边界，什么时候用应用内浏览器，什么时候用你连着的Chrome扩展，什么时候用电脑，这些都很有讲究，而且都是靠感觉摸索出来的。我前几天看到一个很棒的推特帖子，描述了这三者以及各自的用途。
对。
所以，这个人描述得真好。
这些个人工作流真的很有意思，因为有些真的挺好用的，比如大家都在试各种东西，每个人都在搞自己的个人系统。你问这里每个人他们做什么，答案都不一样，然后就会出现一些共性，我们就会说，这个应该做成应用里的一等公民体验。我们应该把大家似乎都在弄的这个东西，做出来让大家直接好用。
对，而且我觉得记忆功能现在有点这种形状，我们有很多人，其他公司也有很多人，他们说：“我建了个Obsidian库或者Notion空间，我教它怎么构建我的记忆宫殿，怎么放东西。”
但我觉得，不一定每个人都需要那样，应该有个记忆功能直接帮你做了，那种通用的东西。所以这是其中一个，但还有其他。
就像你工作流程的一部分，有些东西你确实应该设置好，但我觉得我们一直在不断摸索，什么对个人最有效，什么应该进入产品，什么应该保持原样，就像‘那只是你工作的一部分’那样，什么应该成为基础功能，什么不应该。
没错，这就是你之前提到的品味和判断力。我想谈谈浏览器使用这部分，因为我觉得人们还没意识到这有多强大，以及它能用来做什么。
这让我想起，不知道你有没有看丹·希珀上播客那期，他有个预测，说我们很快会开始在Codex里面运行我们的SaaS应用。
是的。
所以，不用再打开Chrome了。
我知道他每天都给我发Slack消息要这要那的。你觉得我们真的会变成那样吗？就在Codex应用里工作，用Notion、Linear、Salesforce，然后有你的智能体在旁边帮忙？还是说那是另一个方向？
这真的很有意思，因为我们显然尝试过几次浏览器形态的活动，对吧？有Operator、Tragic的代理模式、Atlas，现在我们有桌面应用里的内置浏览器。我们还能安装Chrome扩展，让应用连接到Chrome。我们尝试过很多形式，也学到了很多东西。有很多因素在起作用，也有很多很无聊的因素。比如，我们最初发布的应用是Electron应用。内置浏览器能做的事情有限，而且有点卡。所以内置浏览器最初是为了开发用的，用来测试你的前端。我们当时觉得它不适合其他用途。它就是个开发者工具，对吧？然后我们切换到了我们的Owl堆栈，也就是支持Atlas浏览器的那个。现在有了多标签，还有企业级安全，这样你就能登录所有网站，如果你需要的话。所以我们一直在迭代这个。我觉得难点一直在于，这个浏览器应该是什么形态？是只给智能体用吗？就像你有Chrome，你打开Chrome做你的事，如果你问桌面应用，它会打开这个它能快速控制的浏览器，没有Playwright的延迟，等等。还是说我们想把这个应用做成万能浏览器，让你把它当浏览器用？这两种选择有很多权衡，而且这也不是一条成熟的路，对吧？大多数浏览器都是顶级浏览器，有标签页。这会产生很多无聊但繁琐的问题，比如键盘快捷键。我们是尝试做键位映射到VS Code、Chrome、我们自己的东西，还是Linear？我们想保留一些肌肉记忆，但市面上这些产品都有不同的形状和子形状。我们该怎么办？这就凸显了这个应用有多难，它必须对从未构建过东西的人也能用。
从更基础的用户，到像彼得那样的高级用户。
Open Claw试着用它写代码。
我不确定能让彼得用这个应用。我觉得他可能是最后一个坚持用终端的人。好吧。
但我会继续尝试。
好的，让我先退一步，谈谈大局，你们把这些带到哪里去。Codex的愿景是什么？它会怎么发展？会变成什么样？比如一两年后，或者十年后。
我们一开始有Codex作为命令行工具，然后决定构建这个应用。当时我们对这个应用有点不确定，但对其潜力很有信心，就是作为开发者工具。对吧？
是的。
而且它不会成为一个IDE，而是这样一个大小适中的界面，类似聊天机器人，但不止于此。你可以看到代码，但我们不打算让你编辑代码。
一月份到二月份，OpenAI发生了一件有趣的事情，那是在我们正式发布Codex应用之前。我们开始内部试用Codex应用，发现我们正在趋近于一个相当清晰的内部产品市场契合点，特别是在工程和研究工作流程上。
他们非常兴奋，非常喜欢。我们想，好吧，我们只需要在向世界发布之前提高质量标准。我们确信这会成为一件大事。
但在公司内部，我们又启动了其他一些工作流程，想说，嘿，这个Codex项目在编码代理方面有潜力。我们有来自市场、通讯、财务、法务，基本上每个领域的人都在使用Codex应用。
尽管这个应用对这些人来说实际上是充满敌意的，它试图向他们展示代码，试图请求批准运行RG，它做的这些事情都不是他们真正的产品界面。
那么，我们为什么不把我们的其他界面也加入Codex呢？比如加入ChatGPT桌面应用，加入Atlas浏览器？让我们本质上吸取Codex的经验，使其更通用，适用于一般的知识工作工具。
这些努力进行了一段时间，然后出现了最令人烦恼的问题：没有人离开Codex应用，去使用那些据说为其他人群设计的应用。
我认为这一切的教训是，开发者工具与通用知识工作工具之间有很多细微差别，并不是非此即彼。我们非常坚信这一点。
就像我们说你的角色的平均值是什么，在产品方面也是一样。做Excel工作的人不想看到Git仓库信息。我们知道这一点。
但我们也知道，我们可以从他们的行为中看出他们做的是什么样的工作，我们可以从简单开始，随着需要让产品变得复杂。对吗？这并不意味着我们不需要模式。
你可能需要一些模式来组织你的东西，并让你清楚地了解进入体验的方式。但我们真的坚信，我们构建的东西是正确的形态，可以应对深入的垂直领域。
我们与财务团队、科学团队、法务团队深入合作，我们说，如果我们能构建正确的可扩展性原语和正确的通用模型，那你就能用它做任何事。
然后我们的挑战是如何推广它。但这又回到了我们能构建的最好的桌面应用是什么样的？所以，你知道，Codex是开发者工具，ChatGPT又是什么？这就是我们的思考方式。
它本身不是编辑器，对吧？它没有任何那种界面，但它能理解他使用的是Premiere Pro。它可以通过编辑支撑Premiere Pro屏幕显示的那些文件来做一些编辑，但它不能
做所有事。所以自然地，Codex就给自己构建了一个扩展，可以安装到Premiere Pro里，然后它就可以跟那个扩展对话，说：‘嘿，Premiere Pro扩展，你能帮我改一下Premiere Pro应用里的这个标记吗？’
当我们看到这种情况发生时，那真是相当疯狂。嗯，这是一个很好的模式，对吧？这些专业工具各有所长，所以我们试图用Codex和
现在用ChatGPT同时做两件事：一是我们如何与你已经使用的这些工具无缝互动，比如我们不需要为你构建一个更好的视频编辑器，对吧？但Codex和ChatGPT可以使用那个视频编辑器，对吧？它可以
进行交互，可以把手头的事情交给它，对吧？所以那怎么做呢？通常是通过连接器、计算机使用，或者在这种情况下甚至扩展。然后还有Dan Shepard的做法，那就是，嘿，我有
这些网页应用，你可以点击使用，但我想在Codex里打开它们，然后让Codex用它们做额外的事情，对吧？所以这就是两种几乎互为镜像的模式，我们同时在这两方面做了
很多工作。
>> 这个Premiere的故事对我来说很有趣，因为这是另一个例子，说明对于这些AI工作要更有雄心。你可能不知道，也许它们能做这件事。几乎就是去试试看，看看它能不能解决。
我要把我们带到播客的一个常设环节，我称之为失败角落。那么问题来了，人们看到像你这样的人，看起来一帆风顺，不断成长。一切都在赢。Codex表现那么好。这个疯狂的
职业生涯，一切都直线上升。人们可能看不到那些事情不顺利、你推出的东西失败了的时刻。所以这些故事对人们来说真的很重要，要让他们知道并非总是
一直赢。你有没有一个在职业生涯中失败的经历，教会了你非常重要的事情？听你这么说我有点觉得有趣，这也许是我第一次没有
感觉自己是个失败者。我的意思是，我当了好长时间创业公司创始人。最后基本上是把公司卖掉了，对吧？那真是好多年。那段历程非常艰难。是监管很严格的领域。整个过程感觉
像是一直在失败。然后我去了另一家创业公司，我们试图做AI工具，同样在一个非常封闭和监管严格的行业，那感觉就是一次又一次尝试，却都不成功。所以
对我来说，我其实失败了很多次，你知道，有时候就是时机对了，比如技能、热情和市场时机契合了。我们通过这个项目把我们从Codex应用中学到的东西和
ChatGPT结合起来。这里不知道有多少次微小的失败，我们说‘这应该是这个形状’，然后把它扔到Slack里，结果有2000条消息的讨论串说我们有多蠢。
而且这正是我喜欢OpenAI的地方，人们会直接告诉我们，对吧？当我们内部产品失败时，他们毫不留情。正因为如此，外部产品
一直相当不错，因为它经历了这些循环，就像
>> 2000人觉得这很烂
>> 我失败了大概10到15年才走到这一步，所以我现在每天仍然惊讶于事情进展顺利。我知道，但我还是觉得……
>> 我觉得这对人们来说真的很重要，你可以有很多事情不顺利，然后事情开始变得非常好，只要继续前进，不断学习，我想这就是一个教训。好了，我们
到了非常令人兴奋的快速问答环节。我有五个问题要问你。
>> 太好了，开始吧。嗯，有两三本书是你最常推荐给别人的吗？
>> 你看，我现在是个家长了。我是小孩子的家长，所以我不太确定。有一本叫《咕噜牛》的书，给我的孩子们看的。哦天哪，我们孩子最近对咕噜牛着迷了。
>> 是的。
>> 嗯，我们有个睡前清单，现在就是睡衣、刷牙、书、咕噜牛，还有小毯子。
嗯。
嗯，真不错。
我现在看的其他书也是这种风格。其实《咕噜牛》也不算差，我觉得有些书更一般。
好温馨啊。虽然每本童书都跟生死有关，不是谁吃谁，就是谁杀谁，总有点谋杀之类的阴暗面。
对对，还有毁灭。
还有暴力。
即使对他们来说感觉不到暴力，但字里行间还是有。
这会形成一种情节弧线和紧张感。
嗯。
嗯，好的，选《咕噜牛》不错。
我手头积了一大堆书，我得全部看完。
你孩子还喜欢其他童书吗？
说到这个，我对童书可熟了。我最喜欢的一本是一本很老的书，叫《大橙点》之类的。你可以查查，真的很棒，去买吧。如果你
讨厌业主协会，那就去买。这本书讲的是普拉姆先生，他住在一个所有房子都一样的街上，街道很整洁。有一天，一只鸟把一大罐橙色油漆丢到他房子上，他就说：‘管它呢。’
‘我要大干一场。’于是他去店里买了油漆、吊床、鳄鱼什么的，彻底把房子翻新了。邻居们都炸锅了，你知道的，业主协会、房产价值之类的。
这本书其实不是讲业主协会的，但我本人非常反感业主协会。这书真的很酷。然后邻居们一个一个去跟他谈，喝了他们所谓的柠檬水，但那柠檬水很有说服力，因为一个一个，
他们全都开始翻新自己的房子。比如有个家伙把房子弄成了船的样子。我觉得这本书很好，特别是那些刚买房的新手，应该读一读。
我从这里面听到的是自主权。
对，就是自主权。你可以直接去做事情。
直接去做。太棒了。好，我们继续。最近有没有喜欢看的电影或电视剧？有空的话。
《神奇校车》回归了，在Netflix上，是新的动画版。里面有凯特·麦克金农配音，因为弗瑞丝老师现在成了弗瑞丝教授，她还在，但已经不是主角了，凯特·麦克金农配
主角弗瑞丝老师。我一直挺喜欢《神奇校车》的。
我从来没看过。
我个人没时间看电影，所以我就连续看Netflix的剧。你知道那种做法，就是
哦，我坐不住看整部电影，然后看几集剧，保持，
我确实这么做了。这玩意儿有点让人上瘾。
你最近发现的最喜欢的产品是什么？
什么是个糟糕的答案？我感觉我每天都在发现我们的产品。太棒了。
真是这样。
我觉得Linear做得很好。在Linear之前，Linear一直是我最喜欢的软件产品。
你们就是用这个来规划工作的吗？
嗯，理论上是的。
你有没有最喜欢的人生格言，在工作或生活中常常会想起的？我想问每个和我一起工作的人这个问题，因为我觉得我不是一个爱用格言的人，但别人常告诉我我常说的一些话。
是啊。比如我们在聊这些之前，有很多小点让我印象深刻，我已经把它们融入到这个对话中了。我完全理解你说的。好的，最后一个问题。你做过产品经理、设计师和工程师。哪个
是三者中最难的角色？哪个更难搞？[笑声]
是的。我知道。我觉得它们都非常不同。让一个人觉得困难的事情可能对另一个人来说很容易。关于这个三角关系有很多看法。这个三角关系会怎么发展呢？
比如设计师是不是没用了，或者设计师应该写代码吗？产品经理是不是没用了？工程师呢，我们还需要工程师吗？因为产品经理会写所有代码？或者设计师现在要去做产品经理了？然后所有人都没用了，
所有人都一样，我不知道，似乎有一些融合。出现了一些流动性，我觉得这很新鲜也很棒，尤其是对那些有主动性、想去做
需要做的事情的人来说。同时，像我们说的，有些事情不应该消失，但我认为人们应该找到值得做的事情，然后去想办法做那些事。这是
一个很棒的结束方式。Andrew，非常感谢你的到来。
谢谢。大家再见。非常感谢收听。如果你觉得有价值，可以在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你最喜欢的播客应用上订阅这个节目。另外，请考虑给我们评分或留言评论，这真的能帮助
其他听众找到这个播客。你可以在lennispodcast.com找到所有过去的节目或了解更多信息。下集再见。我喜欢那个关于Premiere里Brent的东西。
是的，
那很酷。我也用过编辑功能。基本上就是
简单的事情，比如，你能把它剪成三段吗，你知道，如果对话中有停顿，第二个和CEX能理解。基本上，我们觉得每个工作都始于这样一个故事，
就是产品不是为此设计的，但它是一个空白的聊天机器人，能写代码。所以什么都能做，但像什么
有哪些有用的事情它能做呢，
对吧？我的意思是，人们只需要对项目有好奇心。他们必须，
你知道，有一个明确的目标，然后把Codex作为一个平台来实现，看看会发生什么，
因为完全没有风险。
对吧？就几个token而已。
几个token。
但当然，如果你在OpenAI工作，这方面的风险就小多了。
是啊，你问过
其中一个人，或者其实很多人，问的是哪些技能重要，然后你也聊到过那种超级厉害的新毕业生，对比
嗯
我不知道你是不是非得守着现有的流程不变。我也不确定该给什么建议，但要说一条的话，就是别死守着你的流程不放。要守住的是
你独一无二能带来的成果
然后去改变你的流程，去尝试新东西。就像
你不断
我最擅长理解Figma的自动布局，比如
对
你在干嘛？
对吧？因为AI也会在这方面变得更强。
你就不断抛出有趣的点子。
保持住。这种自我认知水平，想跟AI一起成功，真是疯了。
确实。
是啊。
这也是为什么我不敢轻易说事情会怎样发展，因为我想着我父母也是思想开放的人，他们也投入事业，但这里行得通的东西，就是不会
对所有人都行得通。这话不太好听，但确实是这样，
你知道，但这里的人都是自我选择的，比如，‘哦，我是那种能琢磨出下一步该干嘛的人’，而大多数人不会成为早期采用者。
而且老是得重新学东西，也挺让人沮丧的。是啊。
你知道，就像‘该死’，
又得学个新东西。
是啊。我讨厌重复。这算是我个人的毛病。也正因为这样，我从来不是最好的媒体人，因为我就是讨厌重复自己说过的话。
完美。
嗯，当创始人真惨，如果你讨厌重复自己的话，因为那你得不断重复讲。
就像个复读机兼主管。
所以对我来说，如果能每天以不同的方式做我的工作，那太棒了。
但那样的话，就不是...
你为你的工作找到了产品市场契合点。
没错，是啊。不，那就是我，我其实没法谈判，因为我说，我不想要别的工作。[笑声] 真了不起，老兄。